greed fraud dishonesty and arrogance
these are some of the words that best
describe the reality of Wall Street
today if Wall Street does not end its
greed we will end it for them today
three out of the four largest financial
institutions JPMorgan Chase Bank of
America and Wells Fargo are nearly 80
percent bigger than before we bailed
them out because they were too big to
fail if a bank is too big to fail it is
too big to exist within the first 100
days of my administration I will require
the secretary of the Treasury Department
to establish a too big to fail list of
commercial banks shadow banks and
insurance companies whose failure would
pose a catastrophic risk to the United
States economy without a taxpayer
bailout within one year my
administration will break these
institutions up so that they no longer
pose no longer pose a grave threat to
the economy not one major Wall Street
executive has ever been prosecuted for
causing the near collapse of our entire
economy that will change under my
administration
further we need to structurally reform
the Federal Reserve when Wall Street was
on the verge of collapse the Federal
Reserve acted with a fierce sense of
urgency to save the financial system we
need the Fed to act with that same
boldness today that fierce sense of
urgency to combat unemployment and low
wages the Federal Reserve has been
hijacked by the very Bank is it is in
charge of regulating if elected
president I will rein in Wall Street so
they cannot crash our economy again will
the folks on Wall Street like me no will
they begin to play by the rules if I am
president you better believe it